we are here on nbc sports on peacock
we're part of the peacock family you can
watch the office here on peacock and
then speaking of the office the man who
played andy bernard for all of those
years
he and randall park together are in a
fun new show called true story with ed
and randall available now on peacock
joining us here on the rich eisen show
is the man himself ed helms how are you
sir
hey i'm fantastic how are you
i'm doing better for talking to you i'm
a very big fan of your work
very big thank you so much
yeah i think we've been trying to get
this i've been like we've been trying to
get on this show for
yeah so you've got like scheduled it
yeah i feel like it's it's been a saga
but i'm i'm glad to be here i am very
glad that it was all done cause look we
were all rowing in the same peacock
direction we're on the same boat and
we're trying to all row for more
streaming and more downloads for
everybody you know amen there's an i
enrich in on eisen but i'm a team player
and again um okay this show that you're
doing uh i love the idea so again
uh
you and randall park are sitting there
and hearing a story for the first time
that it's a true story and i love the
first story here especially since it
does play into the sports conversation
that we do have here every day
so i'll give you the floor tell me about
rick steigerwald and how this plays into
your show
your first guest
ed uh great so yeah he's con this he's
completely insane but i'll start with
just a little recap of the premise so
people kind of understand what the show
is it's like a you know it's kind of a
hybrid reality slash scripted show
where randall park and i sit down
with just a just a real everyday
average person who happens to have
an incredible crazy true story from
their lives
we sit down with them randall and i have
never heard the story before
we have a we have a
sort of like a back and forth just we
interview them and hear the story from
them
and
then the really that which is incredibly
fun and would be a great show on its own
but then we actually go and shoot these
big reenactments it's kind of like
cinematic reenactment of the story
and that gets kind of intercut with the
the interview for the final product
and it's a really like it's an
incredibly funny show but
because the stories are true and because
these people are being so vulnerable and
sharing these stories with us it's also
very kind of heartwarming and uplifting
at times and
you know it just celebrates that lost
art of
of laughing at ourselves like people
people like telling stories that are
oftentimes embarrassing or humiliating
in some way
but just with a great sense of humor and
and kind of like humility
um so that's what the show is the our
first episode is this guy you mentioned
rick staggerwald tigerwald
and he is
like if i if i met him in a bar
somewhere i'd be like this guy's a con
man it's like nothing he says is true
but it's true story but it's a true
story but it is
like it has been completely fact checked
his entire story checked out and what it
is is he
in the 70s he's uh um
he's uh he was a welder in in pittsburgh
town usa
and of course
uh
just a die-hard steelers fan as the
whole city is
um but in the in the late 70s i think it
was 79
was the steeler was terry bradshaw
taking the steelers to um
the super bowl in miami
and uh
he and his brothers who were just the
like who were around 20 something
at the time
and just the most
raucous
ravelrousing crew rent to winnebago
drive down to
miami for the super bowl and sneak in
and
that is the least crazy part of the
source
that's literally like the that's where
the story begins and from there it just
goes even more and more bananas and it's
so fun and he is such an incredible
character like he's just uh
he's incredibly charming and hilarious
and you just can't believe he's real and
that these stories are real well i mean
and the best part about it let's you
know i i don't mean to to steal too much
thunder because there's enough thunder
to go around from his story uh he winds
up showering with the team he winds up
not only going to the game
but getting his way into the locker room
after the game and stripping down naked
and showering with the team that
literally happened
ed for real
so so spoiler alert yeah he he
he basically
is a guy who just
will stop at nothing
to do whatever is crazier than
like he'll just take a crazier step
every time so they're sitting in the
stands at they they get into the game
they're sitting in the stands and his
buddy's like hey let's try to get the
game ball
and he's like okay
like
sneaks onto the field
and he's on the field at the end of the
game
and uh and of course because everyone's
rushing the field he sees the team
heading back to the locker room he's
like
ah i'll just go in the locker room
because i want to hang out with the
steelers and so he pretends to be a
camera assistant or something
makes his way into the locker room oh my
god and then and then someone i mean i
don't want to get i don't want to spoil
church because there's
because yes but it does wind up with him
in the shower and there's
and if you ask him like why did you take
a shower with the team it's like
the answer is is as simple as because
it's insane it would just it was fun it
sounds like the worst white shadow
episode ever ed
yeah
oh my god
he's the best he's just sort of one of
those guys that you want to hang out
with and just hear about his life and
then the re the reenactment includes
bradshaw you got terry we got this here
yeah so i i did a movie with terry a
couple years ago and
i don't know if you know him at all but
he's of course just the most incredible
wonderful human being
um he is who you think he is who you
think he is will you see him that is him
that is him yes a hundred percent right
and uh and he i called him i said we're
doing this thing this guy actually met
you
uh it back in 79 and
uh
and we want to reenact it
why would do you want to be a part of it
and he's like hell yeah yeah of course
so
um so terry's in it and uh and and adam
pally
who's a great yes uh just an amazing
hilarious actor he plays rick young rick
uh
and it's
it's so fun it's just so fun well i i am
mandated ed helms to follow up and just
button it up i guess with this question
is because again the fact that you're
a newbie to the story too that you're
hearing it as well for the first time
along with randall park and the show
again true story with adam randall on
peacock here with that helms
did you inform terry that he showered
with a perfect stranger after the super
bowl was he aware of this story himself
ed
did you break this news
uh i guess so i don't know who was in
the actual shower
while rick was but yeah basically uh
we uh i mean he was in the locker room
yeah i mean sure like you know
did you know
i i really wanted to i have to tell you
one more amazing detail by the way i'm
so sorry i'm so sorry if i'm forcing you
into spoilers i know that's not i want
people okay good all right no i
i can't help myself like i shouldn't say
this stuff but hopefully
the more the more crazy stuff i tell you
that the more people will want to be
used to honey
honey yes
yes yeah at one point a reporter thinks
that rick is a stealer
and starts to interview him
and he just does the interview
what
does this video exist
does it uh i don't
i we i don't know that that's findable
okay
but it is so priceless but here's what
does exist for sure there were articles
in the in like the miami herald or some
like local paper
about a guy
who snuck into the locker room and
interacted with everybody before he got
kicked out oh my gosh
that's so it's true like every it's all
true wow
true story with adam randle on peacock
you gotta check it out and then there's
some other great stories of some other
regular people i guess the only thing
missing from this story is uh mr chow
hopping out of the trunk of the
winnebago ed you know what i'm saying
you know
that's my job
what i try to do is mix up all of my uh
all of my stuff mix them all up andy
bernard appearance
you know what that's next level that was
also my way to transition um a couple of
questions about this um you know what's
your true story
about mike tyson what do you got for me
about your experience with mike on the
set of the hangover if you had a true
story about mike that's not to be
believed you got a good one
about it
well uh the the
yeah so um
you know he was in both he was in both
hangover one and hangover two yes sir
and in hangover two of course i have his
tattoo
and
i'm not sure that
that
i'm just i don't know if he
totally had
read the script or was briefed on the
script
exactly before he got to thailand to
shoot with us um
but uh when i had when i walked out with
his tattoo on my face for the first day
of shooting with him
he looked so pissed
and i was
terrified
um and then uh there was like 10 minutes
of just like really intense tension and
then he just breaks out with his like
huge laugh oh thank god and
i was like oh my god yes okay mike was
just messing with me and uh rightfully
so
and uh
we had him yeah just had a great time
shooting again well he came on this show
years ago when um i had it sometimes
because we're on radio not to get too
deep in the woods here but i would have
to take a break in the middle of long
interviews just as for the radio
audience
and so it was up to me it was my you
know uh i guess prerogative when to take
that over a certain period of time and i
knew i would have to take a break in the
interview that i had with mike sitting
here so i asked him at one point i said
hey if i could get you back in the ring
how many how many rounds could you go
like now at this age and he says to me i
don't like to think about that because
when i think about boxing it puts me in
a very dark place
at which point i'm like well we'll be
right back you know that's when i took
the breath
oh man that's when i'm like okay i'm
gonna take that break now and then uh
we'll reset and come back yeah
go refresh
now when he hit you when he hit you in
the movie like did he come close i mean
like what what happened there
so that's a common misconception he
actually hit zach uh in a movie so he
did not hit you in the film okay um
right and uh and it was it was you know
the stunt guy comes and like sort of
shows shows you exactly how to do those
big punch moments
and like you know he's showing mike uh
but but mike is a mike's the real deal
so like he doesn't
he doesn't
he's not necessarily going to respond
perfectly to like somebody teaching him
a specific way to punch like he just has
those reflexes
and when
when zach goes down
from that fake punch there was a split
second where i i was like
did that land oh my gosh
was this
or what are you gonna have to call an
ambulance
um
but uh oh my word yeah it's it's
is it true did you ad-lib the song at
the piano with the chicken about doug
did was that off the top of your head in
the hangover
it was it i wrote it that day and i
didn't add lit it in the moment
um
well i wish i wish i were that brilliant
okay but i'm not um
now how many takes did did you at any
point in time during the filming of that
scene realized that you were in fact
playing with a chicken on your piano
ed and the absurdity of it did you get
caught in that or you can you focus you
know i'm i'm i'm a really uh i'm a
really intense actor
so i never i didn't allow myself to
to explore the absurdity i just had to
play the reality of
the moment understood and uh
you're professional i don't i didn't
mean to to besmirch i didn't mean to you
know think yeah
my apologies because i just think it's
just you know
everybody just sitting around and it's
such a you know a poignant moment and
there's a chicken on the piano and
i will tell you there were there were so
many times shooting that movie that we
just could not stop laughing for any
number of reasons whether it was like
something in the script or something
that was happening off camera or just
one of us messing with the other like
it just uh the making of that movie was
one of the greatest
times of my life and i
i just remember it so fondly and i think
um
i think that's a big part of the appeal
of the movie honestly is just how much
fun we were having
making it and that that that somehow
sort of comes across
well it certainly does it in my
estimation ed and this is not a
hyperbole and because you're here either
but the final scene of that film where
you take a look at what's in the camera
is truly one of the funniest greatest
endings in the history of movies it
really is i mean
what a payoff what a finish and i'm
wondering did you
shoot those shots during the film
filming of it in real time like did you
like say okay this is going to be for
the camera shot at the end did you is
that how you guys actually
did that yeah for the hangover yeah so
so
there there are
it's a mix there are
pictures in that final credit sequence
that
are from
that are sort of like
uh additional moments
from scenes in the movie
so and and and for those like when we
would shoot a scene todd the director
would say like okay let's get some
stills for the credits
but then there are a bunch of of they're
a bunch of those photos that
that are just complete surprises like
uh like me in a fist fight with wayne
newton
or
um
the scene where i'm pulling the
my tooth out
you don't you don't ever see any of that
stuff in the
body of the movie so so those were
actual
those were things that we scheduled and
had to go out and
shoot
just just as stills for the credits
who could take a punch more wayne wayne
newton or zack galifianakis who could
take a punch better what do you got for
me
well i think
i think wayne would i can't remember i
haven't seen in a long time but i think
wayne was was kind of kicking my ass oh
right my bad
my bad that's another common
misconception
just amazing man and i i i i would be
remiss certainly since you can see
everything on peacock uh if i did not
ask you before i let you go your
favorite um
scene in the office that you were
involved in one that you're particularly
fond of proud of anything on that front
yeah
it's really hard to
really hard to pick i bet um
there are so many fun ones but i i do
i think the
the
scene one of the scenes that sticks with
me a lot because i it was one of the
most exciting things for me to shoot
uh was when
andy arrives at
thunder mifflin for the first time or he
arrives in the scranton branch for the
first time
so
he's kind of like
figured out that he wants to like mimic
and mirror michael scott as a as a sort
of
way to get in his good graces
um and that first
episode where he's trying to kind of
butter up michael scott
i just it was my first
those were my first scenes working with
steve
and he's just so incredible and so funny
and
i i just remember though that that first
episode of being in scranton as like
like oh wow this is
this is so so cool i'm just so excited
to be here
um
and i also it was the first time i
really understood how
unfathomably funny steve carell is like
when you're in the same space with him
i had such a hard time
keeping from breaking with him and i
like so over the years it never got
easier and i wound up developing a trick
which somebody told me this is something
that i think a lot of actors use and
when they're
when they have to try not to laugh
i would rarely look steve in the eye
during a state during a scene
i would usually be looking at his chin
or his ear
or like some some neutral spot
so that i wasn't actually feeling the
just like
tsunami of comedy coming at me because i
would be laughing too hard
i love that that's a great true story
right there um thanks for the time ed
like i said big fan i could go on and on
like this for a long time i appreciate
you
uh coming on here right here on peacock
true story with ed and randall
yeah right on i'm really glad to be here
rich i i i would love to be back soon
excellent and uh thanks for having me
anytime man ed helms on twitter and
instagram thanks again you go uh fourth
and i can't wait to see more
of your show thank you for being here
right on you got it ed helms everybody
right here on the rich eisen show
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here